That pseudo code asked us to let i go from zero to the length over 2 minus 1.
That minus one is always a little inelegant, I prefer to use the less than sign
here. Inside the loop, we were supposed to swap the position i and i plus
length over 2. Let's copy and paste the swap code. Here it is, but now j, of
course, is supposed to be this. Now I fixed up the code. And I'm ready to run.
Here you see the result, the array before and after swapping. And you can see
these numbers are now where they're supposed to be, as well as for the other
half. I want to briefly talk about the code that produced this printout here.
When you look over here, we call system.out.println and we can't directly print
elements. As I said, arrays are more primitive then array lists, and an array
will not print out its value. This method here takes an array and turns it into
a string that lists all of the values inside. Though when you want to print out
an array list, you can directly pass it out to System.out.printIn. When you
have an array, you have to use this helper method. Of course you could also use
a direct loop, but the helper method is more convenient. Now remember what the
point of all of this was, the point was not how to implement the swapping
algorithm in Javam the exciting thing was how we discovered it in the first
place, we discovered it by playing around with stuff and not by worrying about
exactly how the index values were or whether we needed a For loop or a While
loop and I hope that's the lesson that stays with you, if you need to do
something that's off the beaten track, that's different from what you've seen
before. Get out some Lego bricks, some coins, some candies, whatever, and
figure out what the operation would be with those. And that'll give you the
intuition that you need in order to be a successful programmer. Programming is
all about having the right ideas and the right intuition, not about pushing the
symbols of the programming language around.